I never believed the whole I'm happy
single spiel that's like this is real
it took me a long time but I'm very
happy I call it being south partners
Emma Watson introducing us to a new term
it just feels really good to have it out
there in the world the actress is a
vision in red on the December cover of
British Vogue hitting newsstands on
November 8th and in the interview she
opens up about how she really feels
about her upcoming 30th birthday feel so
stressed and anxious and I realize it's
because there are there is suddenly this
bloody influx of subliminal messaging
around if you if you do not have a if
you have not built a home if you do not
have a husband if you do not have a baby
and you are turning 30 only I knew not
is something like incredibly like secure
stable place in your career we are still
figuring things out there's just like
this incredible amount of anxiety oh we
feel you AMA but despite all the
societal pressures and expectations
she says she's happily single I am
dating yeah
as in there's a not one specific person
but I'm going on okay my friends are
really good setting me up yeah really
good and and what's really nice is even
things that even things that haven't
worked out romantically some of my best
friends are people I got set up on a
date with the famous activist also gets
candid about her struggles with Fame and
how its led her to seek help that's
another thing I've sat in therapy and
felt really guilty about to be honest is
is like why why me why somebody else
would have enjoyed and wanted this
aspect of it more than I did
right and I struggle with I've wrestled
a lot with the guilt around that I've
just I've been like I should be enjoying
this more yeah I should be more excited
and I'm actually really struggling of
course emma is referring to being cast
in the Harry Potter films at the ripe
young age of 9
bad for either of you come up with
another plan tried it it was killed was
expelled
she needs to saw her her priorities and
I got literally picked out of a lineup
in my school gym that wasn't even an
acting school and got the first part I
ever auditioned I mean it's like it's so
bizarre another wildly what happened to
me
despite her early rise to fame Watson
has remained incredibly grounded part of
I think my sense of peace within myself
has been in remembering my identity as
like I'm someone's daughter yeah like I
am my mother's daughter I am my father's
daughter I am I am a sister I I belong
to family I come from a place I have
roots and the whole celebrity thing
aside here's the one thing she wishes
people knew about her sometimes I have
to go no no I need exactly what you need
like I'm just as human as you are I'm
just as insecure as you are I struggle
just as much as you struggle
[Music]